est-ce que d'abord il ya des questions
parmi l'équipe très vite qui a des
questions à poser
il faut des lésions vraiment les
questions dont tout le monde se pose
allez c'est parti à enzo qui m'opposait
lequel rouillé c'est que j'apprécie
beaucoup
un bénéfice de ben je pense aux nerfs
est ce que c'est possible que tu arrêtes
de vannes et mon père ou pas 500 morts
parce que c'est possible
un jour alors je vais pouvoir regarder
une émission sans avoir les yeux [ __ ]
ou quoi enzo je vais te dire alors très
bonne question et je vais te décourage
le ban parce que je l'aimais énormément
tu sais c'est comme quand avec tes potes
tu les vannes dans un conduit les tifs
pas quelqu'un tu calcules même pas alors
lui comme je les aime tellement c'est
vraiment mon pote qui s est vraiment con
poteau où tu vois que j'aime bien aussi
on aime on se tape un peu on rigole on
vans et c'est mon pote c'est comme si tu
étais qu'un pote donc forcément tu ne
vas le jour où je le char irait plus
c'est que en fait on sera plus aussi
potes que maintenant ouais je lis donc
non mais c'est mon poto c'est le ferron
voilà dit la vérité c'est vouloir c'est
mon frère c'est un ami brahim hajji donc
atteint ce collage le chari voilà c'est
c'est mon ami c'est mon qui a une autre
question aux yeux pleins de questions et
il ya des questions s'il ya plein de
gens qui ont et qu'ils ont fait à
sabrina par yahia sabrina par exemple
qu'à une question vas-y sabrina sabrina
qui peut nous poser une question m'a dit
sabrina c'est parti on est là ça les
origines s'il vous plaît oui salut
sabrina la lisa du sahara merci sabrina
merci d'être avec nous ma chérie tu as
une question basique ta question c'est
quoi alors ma question c'est pour ce
soir c'est lille 10 mois
alors c'est qu'elles sont les six
chroniqueurs indispensable à l'émission
et pourquoi voilà et sabrina tu me pose
une question du racket un très bon match
et les six chroniqueurs indispensable
émission moi je vais te dire déjà ya
jean michel maire c'est le plus ancien
c'est mon ami est forcément voilà celui
qui est là depuis le début et
c'est ma béquille c'est ma lumière il ya
bien sûr isabelle morini bosc
voilà qui est indispensable à l'émission
également puisque elle aussi ses voix
l'a fait c'est c'la c'est une des plus
anciennes dans l'émission elle a fait
l'histoire de tpm p elle a fait le
succès thé pmp et grâce si grâce à jean
michel et isabelle par exemple qu'on a
pu faire dix ans parce que c'est ce
voilà qu'on était là depuis le début
donc forcément bien sûr isabelle et jean
mi forcément bien sûr ils sont
indispensables
après je dirais également je vais dire
gilles berne et gilles verdez il nous a
énormément manqué en début d'année parce
que gilles verdez il a un avis sur tout
c'est quelqu'un sur qui vraiment on peut
se reposer sur quelqu'un qui est
vraiment dès qu'on a un petit blanc dans
l'émission un truc on sait qu'on peut se
tourner vers gilles et c'est un bosseur
et on sait qu'il aura toujours quelque
chose à dire donc gilles verdez voilà je
te dit sabrina indispensable voilà je le
dis vraiment indispensable ensuite il y
à kelly vdo pays parce que kelly elle a
vraiment trouvé sa place dans l'émission
et c'est la rieuse de l'émission elle
riait nous amène son côté frais elle est
un peu plus jeune que les autres donc
forcément elle a un autre regard que les
autres tant qu'elles amènent autre chose
que les autres dans l'émission donc
voilà kelly bien entendu ensuite il y a
bien entendu benji benjamin castaldi qui
est voilà c'est normal si j'ai pas mal
la main castaldi sur qui je tape mon jeu
je fais quoi je fais quoi les mecs je
fais quoi et ensuite
moi je dirais et franchement il ya et je
vais tenir en vrai y'a pas si le
chroniqueur parce que c'est des tables
de huit ou neuf
après bien sûr il ya mathieu mathieu
inquiète sur ses sites à dire qu'il
aurait deux matches où mathieu raymond
mathieu raymond ils sont indispensables
ouais je dis la vérité mathieu ccc voilà
c'est le spectacle et du fâ spectacle
incroyable et raymond c'est devenu
aujourd'hui pour moi un des piliers de
l'émission vraiment quand je commence à
faire les tables c'est un des premiers
que jamais parce qu'un déjà c'est mon
pote et 2 il est indispensable
après pour les autres je n'aimais pas
dans le top 6 noeuds départ et valérie
n'oublie pas valérie là mais l'armée je
l'aimé pas dans le top 6 ou le top 7
mais je vous le dis voilà c'est mon top
10 ou le top 7 après bernard montiel
bernard montiel il peut pas venir de
gens puissent ils à d'autres activités
donc bernard mais quand il vient c'est
un bonheur je dis la vérité c'est un
bonheur et géraldine maillet aussi elle
peut pas venir tous les jours
géraldine mais géraldine à chaque fois
qu'elle vient elle de venir deux fois
par semaine et à chaque fois je leur
demande d'en faire 3 4 parce que j'adore
quand elle est avec nous mais je vous
parle de ce qui pourrait devenir
vraiment tous les jours et je vous le
dis et je l'annoncerai chroniqueur
d'ailleurs l'année prochaine et et
christophe vraiment je vous dis aussi
christophe il a contribué au succès de
l'émission donc lui voilà c'est un
indéboulonnable jamais je ne lâcherai
mais l'année prochaine je vous dit il
n'y aura que neuf chroniqueur à table et
ils ne changeront jamais il y en a un
autre que j'aime beaucoup aussi autour
de la table c'est maxime guény que
j'adore parce que il est tellement
gentil seychelles bien son personnage à
maxime et c'est quelqu'un j'ai envie de
mettre plus dans l'émission maxime parce
que je les aime énormément voilà mais en
tout cas voilà et tous ceux qui sont là
en tout cas amérique en place mais voilà
les 6,7
voilà qui sont voilà qui sont
aujourd'hui les piliers voilà c'est ça
merci en tout cas sabrina pour ta
question je te dire un truc utile basit
a vu que j'ai été franc ouais ouais
ouais t'as dit lorsque je voudrais juste
vous dire que le 12/12 adore tous
vraiment batana il dit préférer celles
tournées sur les toits gna gna mathieu à
norma tous d'accord je veux qu'elle
m'appelle gerard way ainsi que tu veux
que matthieu chalmé benjamin d'accord ok
way est avec vous mais bon on adore
valérie coquette avec le début
d'émission qu'on embrasse auquel d'amour
je te gros bisous - voilà est juste je
vous suis tous les jours je suis pas un
amour chéri merci sabres landes faim
énorme bisou merci d'avoir est avec nous
on a les yeux on a un tweet
isabelle et gilles est-ce que vous
pouvez nous jurer qu'il n'y a jamais
rien eu entre vous il avait les gilles
alors géante isabelle répondre a ajouté
nyan en premier je jure ce qui a jamais
rien lu sur la tête de qui veut brûler
je suppose qu'il aura jamais rien
alors alors je rappelle qu'il ya à
garlin qui est derrière et non plus un
mais est-ce que vous avez des questions
oui oui vous abaissez bond à la réponse
me dit vas-y gêné mémoire voici déjà
quasi si on avait été célibataire il y
aurait eu ou tout au moins j'aurais tout
fait pour séduire isabelle et bah oui
j'en avais tu es célibataire aussi soit
ce que sur la politique que vous tapez à
bâle et chérie ça sera peut-être dans
une autre vie ça va pas tarder bernard
montiel
ouais j'ai une question pour jean cyril
les raisonnements de tout ce qui se
passe dans les milieux de la télévision
qu'un chroniqueur elle veut rayer rouen
gadji la saison prochaine alors qu'elle
chroniqueurs franchement j'en ai je
trouve ton analyse est une très bonne
équipe mais voilà ghanaian avait là
franchement aujourd'hui pour l'instant
j'ai pas d'idée il ya un mec que j'aime
bien je vous dis la vérité
ce que je suis vous allez me dire
comment bien ce nom est sorti mais c'est
un mec que j'aime bien et j'en ai envie
de qualité en vidant de quelqu'un avec
un accent un peu du sud tout ça jerry
bien jean pascal
j'aime bien jean pascal et c'est
quelqu'un en tant qu'animateur et en
tant que chroniqueur j'y crois à fond et
j'espère faisant devenir son producteur
et je l'aimé beaucoup au téléphone c'est
quelqu'un que je suis voilà jean pascal
rigolent ils aiment bien bas merci merci
bernard j'aime bien jean pascal
oui je re a dit est ce que pendant ces
dix ans cyril tu t'es dit parfois qu'on
avait fait des erreurs de choix de
chroniqueurs ah bah bien sûr là bien sûr
pas de jean neige en effet plaints des
erreurs de choix de chroniqueurs il y en
a plein même kim hee kim qui me le
reproche qui lui souhaitent à fait plein
de que tu t'engages plein de
chroniqueurs et après tu les yeux tu les
prends pas mais forcément il fait que je
teste plein de gens donc voilà donc
forcément voilà c'est sûr que parfois je
me trompe et je me trompe deux fois sur
trois il ya mokhtar qui nous a rejoint
moche eric et qui est très important
pour moi aussi mon mokhtar schéma frérot
ou pas font et que je lâcherai jamais
mon mokhtar d'amour
ça va mon mokhtar ça va être et vous
comment vous avez très bien ce que tu as
une question moshiri déjà vous manquez
beaucoup voient d'accord mais aussi est
gêné savoir un prochain printemps pour
les 10 ans pour un voyage à lorient où
il aura à voyage je vous le dis très
bientôt on est en train de préparer tout
ça forcément date dans la fin du
confinement mais oui on a envie qui est
un voyage alors y'a qu'à tic est avec
une classique qui nous suit un
pratiquement tous les jours et mal cathy
c'est vraiment c'est devenue une amie
voilà le yen fort quatre sièges côte à
une question est ce que tu as un
témoignage à faire pour les dix ans des
pmp qui m'a katyn la merci cathy montaut
merci katibat question va on va régler
question viendra après kelly kelly à une
question
oui à mon sens vous aviez dit que
l'année prochaine
[Musique]
alors je vais en choisir neuf mois je
vous dis et puis bien sûr après y aura
le vendredi avec benjamin
voilà donc qui aura plusieurs langues
qui vont tourner mais il y aura neuf
personnes et l'année prochaine
celui qui veut être dans l'équipe faudra
que soit la du lundi au jeudi je veux
vraiment faire des choses
feuilletonnante c'est à dire des jeux
feuilletons dans les happenings
feuilletonnant donc je veux vraiment des
gens qui soient là du lundi au jeudi à
fond parce que je voulais la vérité pour
moi une émission c'est pas je viens
lundi mardi après je suis plus là dans
les zones d'animation alors que ce soit
dans les autres talk tout le monde est
là tous les jours c'est pas la fête
s'est pas non plus et pas te mettre ces
pages peut dire lundi mercredi et puis
j'aimerais poser d'europe je me reposais
mardi vendredi donc ça cette année c'est
le truc qui m'a vraiment survolé et ça
commençait à massat commence à me
saouler haegeli vraiment il faudra
vraiment quatre 4 jours par semaine
sinon les chéris bien sûr on trouvera
d'autres choses peut-être pour vous mais
je veux vraiment les mêmes du lundi au
jeudi 6 semaine dernière qu'il allait
faire comme un mets donc venir tous les
jours vous allez faire comment pour
faire votre sélection
et bah je sélectionnerais ce que j'ai
envie d'avoir mais je vous dis en tout
cas dans ce que je veux je sais que j'en
venue de jean vaut 10 donc voilà donc a
priori on va on va virer pas bon on va
pas dire ayant donc voilà avait et on
aura voilà qui tourneront si le vendredi
mais dans l'équipe type
j'en veux 9 ou 10
qui ne tourne pas et qu'ils soient avec
nous du lundi au jeudi c'est vraiment
voilà voyons pas dans l'est pour cet
anniversaire
j'annonce des trucs donc là on fera le
débat de demain si vous voulez du shérif
poser d'autres questions mais lundi
c'est vraiment du lundi au jeudi l'année
prochaine c'est vraiment l'annoncent
voilà que je peux vous faire ce soir
week-end question oui benjamin oui c'est
une voix près de dodo dray qui avait
prédit qu'il allait péter la jambe dans
du cassoulet il se trouve que andrea
avait prédit à votre directeur général
younés ce talent elle voyait un arrêt de
l'émission et il trouvait effectivement
grâce au confinement il ya une âme et
squelettes mans series grâce au
confinement à cause du conflit à cause
de conserver des conseillers est ce que
pendant 2 3 jours vous avez eu le
sentiment que le seul s'ouvrait sous vos
pieds parce qu'effectivement comment
tourner hyper actif comme vous avec des
émissions avec le mardi avec toutes les
émissions que vous avez escaut nettement
pendant trois mois j'ai eu
vous avez eu peur et ça ce que veut dire
[ __ ] qu'est-ce qui se passe je veux
savoir s'il y avait au fond de vous même
alors non mais franchement je vous dire
moi j'ai pensé la première chose à
laquelle j'ai pensé c'est comment rester
à l'antenne et comment accompagner
encore les gens pendant ces jours de
confinement c'est la première chose à
laquelle j'ai pensé et j'ai dit tout de
suite aux équipes j'avais déjà anticipé
avant parce que c'est vrai que je
l'avais dit je sens vous avez vous je
vous avais même jour peut-être tourner
notre site fini j'avais planté des
caméras automatiques déjà j'avais
demandée dès jamais équipe de voir
comment on pouvait mettre des caméras
automatiques
déjà il ya un mois et demi de cela même
deux mois j'avais senti un petit peu le
truc arrivé j'avais 10 ou en studio ou
bien chez moi mais j'avais déjà anticipé
le truc donc je savais que j'allais
faire l'émission de chez moi très très
vite et que j'allais anticipé ça pour
pas laisser les gens voient la seule et
même budgétairement on va pas se mentir
voilà c'est 8 ils peuvent pas payer
voilà les missions comme il paye t pmp
donc forcément on s'est dit voilà on va
essayer de faire une émission vraiment
pas cher pour pour vraiment voilà payer
les livres des personnes qui à pays qui
travaillent de chez elle mais c'est tout
voilà et voilà donc on s'est dit voilà
il va faire une émission pour rester à
l'antenne et pour accompagner les
téléspectateurs le plus possible lors du
confinement donc vraiment c'est le
première chose à laquelle j'ai pensé et
j'avais un petit peu anticipé le truc
oui gilles verdez moi j'ai une question
vous tente à temps les abeilles et
gilles pierre j'ai une question pour
vous si ray elle concerne quelque chose
qui est fondamental à mon avis c'est le
lien que l'émission et surtout le vous
vous avez entretenu avec les
téléspectateurs est-ce que ça les francs
12 août où les autres est-ce que ça
c'est pas votre plus belle réussite au
delà du succès aux dates a réussi c'est
ce lien indéfectible dont les vois
encore ils vous suivent la ja et des
centaines de milliers des millions de
gens qui vous suivent
est-ce que ça c'est pas la plus belle
chose qui nous soit arrivée alors bas
après après bien sûr après après ma
famille bien sûr voilà et bien sûr et
les fans jouent le public parce qu'il
n'ya pas que des fans 12 ans parce que
voilà il ya les fans vous il ya des gens
qui ont rendu aussi cette appellation un
peu péjorative les fans nous c'était une
blague qu'on avait fait avec camille de
longs bras sans quoi on verra la vidéo
de camille de maquis et très drôle qui
nous a laissés pas ce qu'on fera qui
veut gagner des milliers mais juste les
chéris je vous le dis voilà moi
aujourd'hui j'ai on a un lien vraiment
qui est indéfectible moi je sais que
tous les dimanches soir par exemple je
fais mon tweet du dimanche soir et je
vois qu'il ya des millions de gens qui
attendent mon tweet qui me disent cyril
on ne veut pas aller dormir tant que tu
as fait ton tweet du dimanche soir et
c'est vrai que voilà c'est c'est un truc
énorme qui s'est passé et et ils me
permettent de tenir aussi tous les jours
et d'être avec vous et de pouvoir voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on quand il ya eu ce
confinement j'ai dit comment je vais
faire pour rester au contact du public
donc j'essaie tout mettre en oeuvre pour
pas vous lâcher et pour essayer d'être
avec vous le plus possible oui question
que des questions les chéris oui la
question en question est un oui moi
isabelle à l'hérésie isabelle vas-y vous
l'avez senti parce que moi je me
souviens que la première fois vous avez
parlé d'un concrètement à tous dans une
maison pendant des dizaines de jours il
n'y avait pas encore de confinement en
italie est maintenue thiery mais il est
un fait pourquoi pourquoi il dit ça ça
ne se passera jamais et qu voir justice
était à grands jets premier film en
europe donc moi je voulais non mais non
mais j'avais on avait quelques infos de
ce qui se passait en chine il y avait
commencé et ça commençait à monter et je
me suis dit je sens qu'il va y avoir un
confinement en france donc voilà j'ai
ronde a essayé de faire toutes les
et de prendre toutes les mesures pour
que voilà on puisse passer ce
confinement et rester à l'antenne mont
isa mais voilà c'était g j'ai senti un
peu le truc j'ai senti que ça pouvait
arriver donc je me suis dit on va on va
prendre les devants lieu que ça nous
tombe sur la gueule
cathy ma chérie keynote téléspectatrices
témoigne apprendre à mathieu monde chez
russie est-ce que tu as une question ou
non un truc à dire merci cathy c'est
notre chantal ladesou ce soir bon merci
cathy entreprendra de leur machine les
bases et mathieu ouellette chantal
ladesou cyril la question c'est que pour
toi on peut la pause et les chroniqueurs
basique à tout le monde
vas-y monde alors question pokerstars
ben si demain tf1 t'appeler pour te
proposer d'animer the voice
en toute sincérité de barques ou tueur
est alors alors jamais de la vie je me
barre mais jamais la vie de jouer bas de
voyous tu parles de ce programme qui
quitte un petit peu un petit peu usé
quand même d'accord donc tu n'y vas pas
les gares et points d'eau à ta question
non non je ne vais pas non mais j'y vais
pas et puis honnêtement je vais vous
dire une chose très très très juste
j'ai eu la chance d'apprendre beaucoup
de choses avec cheryl notamment la
liberté de paie des 100 pts ont peur en
direct sans contrainte sans barrière il
ya des ponts j'ai découvert un ange pour
une foule d'animations que je
connaissais pas et je me suis prends mon
pied tous les jours voilà merci et bon
benji merci mon chéri questions de
jean-michel vas-y oui série une question
pour toi tu te cache pas d'adorer la
villa est ce que tu espères toujours la
faire revenir
alors franchement je l'adorent nabila
franchement c'est vrai que je suis fan
des st amour puce elle m'a jamais lâchée
elle n'a jamais craché dans la soupe
elle a toujours été d'une droiture
incroyable et je l'aiderai toujours même
si elle a pas besoin de moi voilà mais
non une franchement autant de produits
que je pense que david allait passer à
autre chose je les adore vraiment
j'adore la voir en invités qu'ils
adorent mais c'est vrai que l'habillage
pense qu'elle a envie de faire d'autres
trucs elle est un peu un habitat dubaï
tout ça donc non secrètement bien sûr
c'est un jour à leur venir je les aime
tellement voilà fait ce qu'elle veut
je préfère plein truc que je préfère est
plus là produire sur d'autres trucs mais
dans l'émission voilà je crois qu'elle
avait fait le tour même elle voit la meo
nabila voilà on sait que c'est le
lâcherai jamais mais vraiment je donne
beaucoup question il ya une question de
gènes et un tweet je sais pas c'est un
tweet dash md voilà qui nous dit assez
pour toi mathieu mathieu pour toi si
lille est un génie ou un escroc tiens
c'est comme un professeur ou du temps
c'est pourquoi il question c'est drôle
ça ni l'un ni l'autre
en revanche c'est à dire
qu'effectivement j'ai rarement vu un
vrai sens du rythme et de ce qui va
marcher ou pas et de ce qu'il faut
mettre à l'antenne ou pas à nous de dire
que ce qu'on a vu ce soir
dans la séquence là avec tous les
artistes ça va être un match
voilà le vrai talent c'est de casser un
conducteur comme on a vu justement que
mec qui avait mis des menottes qu'ils
avaient toutes un conducteur on a fait
une heure 42 voilà ça en revanche je
reconnais le tue le génie de la télé la
version voiture mais je crois aussi un
peu escroc un peu quand même aussi je
dois parler des on est en direct
si tu peux te dire alors je râle d'une
base ma cellule comme des super
instinctif et intuitif et on voit tous
les jours
est ce que tu as déjà réfléchi dans ta
petite tête alda grant est à la première
émission poste confinement alors la
première édition poste confinement ouais
alors j'ai déjà réfléchi j'ai pour
projet j'ai pour projet comme on a été
peaufiné pendant des semaines et des
semaines j'ai pour projet de faire toute
une émission à l'extérieur avec tout le
public à l'extérieur mais avec des
artistes à l'extérieur et qu'on fasse
une grande scène à l'extérieur et qu'on
fasse lui dénient génial ça en plein air
pour bien sûr voilà être dehors voilà on
a été confinée pendant des semaines et
des semaines pour pouvoir être dehors
donc voilà c'est mon projet par la
machinerie bas j'espère que vous en
serez mais voilà faire un gros truc
voilà pour une fois on l'a on va dire on
va sortir on fera une émission dehors
dans une arène c'est page est en train
de chercher un truc doit voyager en
train de chercher
pas qu'on va sortir christophe carrière
oui une question blanc même pendant
longtemps et une rumeur qui disait qu
total et peut-être changer de chaîne et
si dubouch de chaîne est d'abord reste
c'est le cas et ce serait où alors
d'ailleurs je bougerai pas de chaîne à
je voulais dit tu as acheté dans le
groupe canal parce que c'est la famille
voilà et je les lâcherai jamais comme
eux ils ne m'ont pas lâché mais bien sûr
vous le savez je m'en suis jamais caché
aussi si je dois bouger dans une chaîne
ou dans un groupe ce sera dans le groupe
m6 me suis dit que je m'entends très
bien avec le groupe m6 j'aime beaucoup
ce qu'ils font nicolas de tavernot est
un homme vraiment c'est le pdg de m6
c'est un garçon exceptionnel du j'admire
énormément et avec qui j'ai de très bons
rapports
mais ça reste un ami gestion chypre je
pense qu'on travaillera jamais ensemble
que je vais rester dans le canal mais
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime énormément et
il le sait et il a très souvent été là
quand j'ai eu des petits soucis et c'est
quelqu'un vraiment que j'admire et que
j'aime beaucoup
voilà et il le sait voilà et que ce soit
notre open il double tout le groupe
insiste que ce soit jérôme fouqueray w9
qui est un ami aussi
voilà c'est vraiment des amis fred de
vincelles tout ça toute la direction de
m6 c'est vraiment des amis régis ravanas
d'rtl aussi c'est tous des potes voilà
que j'aime beaucoup mais après voilà
après je pense qu'on travaillera jamais
ensemble
mais on s'aime beaucoup oui alors
question à quatre tirs veulent une sa
ducati ou pas capté auto rappelle t on
l'entend pas du tout où on l'entend pas
du tout katie katie auteurs rappellent
ma chérie celle de chantal ladesou de la
soirée le journal on a d'autres
questions regardez on a une question
d'adil regarder une question d'adil de
saint-etienne
regardez en zoom allez vas-y c'est parti
adil de saint-etienne est ce qu il a
sinon ce qu'il ya une autre question
avant s'il vous plaît avant qu'on le
place
merci ce qui est une question s'il vous
plaît ici a dit lahesalu adil salut à
19,6 des travaux merci d'être là mandat
deal très bien mon chéri tu as une
question pour qu'ils échangent quelques
combats je m'empresse de vie vas-y jeu
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est une bonne question d'adil bravo
pour chérie je te fais un gros bisou
alors répondu tu peux t'on dit oui est
ce qu'elle est de taxi et péter parce
que tu avais pas d'autres propositions
ailleurs alors alors en fait tp mais ça
s'est fait en 2 x séries il a éprouvé
une première fois de venir sur la chaîne
avec jt sur tf1 semble-t-il ou sureau
partance et j'avais un peu plus ou moins
refuser effectivement conseiller m'a
appelée une deuxième fois parce que
j'avais eu un premier passage pour faire
de nouvelles stars eux voilà j'avais dit
je veux pas faire une émission de cyril
comme un con que j'ai fait cette erreur
deux fois effectivement continue il a eu
la meïda leleu la gentillesse de me
rappeler après à vous aimer et virés de
partout effectivement démarre appelé
c'était aux fraudes au fond du trou et
j'ai vu deux boulots question voilà ma
réponse c'est la vérité merci merci at
il d'abord hi tech tout je te fais un
gros bisou mon chéri elle est bon bah
j'ai juste une dédicace à faire quand un
groupe facebook magnifique et tous avec
notre ba ba et ba tan à vous remercie
occulter un beau bijou avec ton mari et
mokhtar on a un point commun on avoue
points communs avec mozilla se construit
c'est que la saison régulière de prix de
billets est terminée malheureusement
brut bien moteur et mokhtar je te fais
un gros kiff avec que j'en suis à bord
est avec tous merci vous gérez bercy
quand une l'air si je t'embrasse fort à
dieu merci d'avoir répondu aux questions
au gîte et gilles verdez vasile des
questions pour vous s'il dit jean c'est
un bel arrêt c'est aussi le temps du
bilan on a vu de chierie on avait une
aura parmi tous les chroniqueurs
ils sont parce qu'ils sont plus là
aujourd'hui elle était selon vous le
meilleur temps alors pour moi selon moi
le meilleur chroniqueur je vous le dis
et je les ai souvent dit il a été très
très bon bien sûr mais celle qui n'a
jamais été remplacé à la table mine de
rien c'est noir on va pas se mentir je
le dis voilà et norrath c'est vrai que
voilà et il y en a eu plein de gens
voilà mes enora voilà moi aujourd'hui
moi je rêve d'une table avec enora
isabelle kelly géraldine voilà et
valérie mais c'est vrai kenora mine de
rien elle avait là c'était elle avait
vraiment un franc parler on va c'est un
peu notre c'est un peu raymond pour moi
car en place et enora franchement voilà
tu vois physiquement non mais en minerai
est un peu toi car on passait mal parce
que c'est vrai que tu as le même franc
parler kenora mon remo et ses vecteurs
pour ça que tu es devenu indispensable
mine de rien aujourd'hui dans l'émission
moshiri est-ce que vous avez d'autres
questions alesi ronde à des questions on
y va mais chérie c'est pas résister à
des questions qu'est une question
moi j'ai une question vas-y mort est mon
nom on a entendu passé on entendu
circulaire en confirmant que tu voulais
nous confiner dans une ville a grandi là
et faire signer chroniqueur dans cette
villa et j'aimerais ça c'est vrai que
les téléspectateurs soient touristes ou
jean avec soit en fumant tu avais eu
cette idée d'emmener tout le monde dans
une villa qui les chroniqueurs de des
pmp est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est une rumeur ce alors j'ai dit est
vrai et je voulais vous et je voulais
pas vous amener dans une village vous
voulez vous amener au studio voilà à
boulogne mettent délit par terre dans
les couloirs partout des caméras qu'on
habite tous ensemble alors je vous le
dis il est pas impossible que si vous
êtes testés négatifs et que tous ceux
qui sont testés négatifs
peut-être qu'on le fera dans un deuxième
temps et qu'on sera tous ensemble voilà
confiné si ça vous chauffe en tout cas
moi ça me choque voilà et pour qu'on
puisse voilà offrir notre notre tranche
de vie à nos tranches de vie tous les
jours aux téléspectateurs on a une
question à quelqu'un sur zoom qui est
avec nous on à anthony salut anthony
merci d'accès à l'orangé une question en
toi syrie va te cite une chose que tu
préfères d'un quotidien plutôt que dans
tpm paix alors ballet quoi pur les
coiffures des personnes présentes
le reste franchement je te jure c'est
vrai j'ai jamais regardé en fait je
regarde pas beaucoup parce qu'on a on en
a en même temps mais voilà les coiffures
voilà je peux dire voilà les coiffures
walla j'adore est-ce que voilà un
message sur toi vas-y mon chéri pas si
ma fille de 7 ans ben vas-y ahmed la
cobas appel aux mannes salut romane
salut chérie je te fais un gros bisou ma
chérie et bosh au mercy romane tant
d'amour shihri merci d'être là mg romane
merci anthony ya un dernier truc à dire
je voudrais dire à mes amis et ma
famille qui me regardent que je les aime
fort merci je t'envoie sans tony berg
six mois que je te fais de gros bijoux
qu'il ya une question allez les chèvres
ont fait les trois dames question ce
soir c'est parti allez vas-y maclure
alain michel cymes joey starr d'alain
régulière bref la liste des gens avec
orgueil les très très longue et ce
canard a aujourd'hui avec qu'ils
n'iraient pas tu regrettes mais avec qui
tu pourras te considères tu voudrais te
réconcilier entre michel cymes joey
starr et qui à michel de la mégère du
hertha berlin de la villardière et je
n'ai aucune autre un scan à à
aujourd'hui midi
non non non mais nagui je suis pas fâché
avec lui
oui j'aime beaucoup elles sont encore eu
par sms il ya trois jours donc nous on
n'a jamais été fâché non non non la
nagui dans ça se passe très bien
arthur ça se passe très bien aussi après
les trois l'acte a dit non je suis pas
comme en août voilà je m'en fout pendant
qu'on est à la limite des 3 détroit je
vais te dire avec qui j'aimerais peut
plus me réconcilier sur les 3 ouais
franchement entre bernard de la
villardière michel cymes et joey starr
ouais joey starr
après entre les trois autres franchement
ouais parce que les deux corps non non
non les attraits de confinement tu peux
le recevoir dans l'émission n'en croient
pas
léa est avec nous vas-y question de
l'erdre alors ma question c'était pour
raymond et salue les a d'ailleurs je
suis sur twitter que j'adore les a merci
d à brasilia alors c'est ma question
c'était pour vraiment si autour de la
table quel est le chroniqueur qui a le
plus déçu
umaga rouleau mal on l'a fait pour ma
gueule parce que ça va être la dernière
et je pense qu'ils se mettent alors
alors je vais te répondre franchement
c'est au tour de l'ain talon qui met à
la télé on t'entend nous y attendions
c'était là mais bon là pantin
voilà il n'est pas très chaud à lunel
merci voilà allez on remercie les à
autre question bercy les attirer pour
l'abandon du parce qu'il veut pas il
veut pas être sur l'appliquons mais tous
merci les chéris dernière question à
l'est qui a une dernière question
prépare une dernière question
jean-mi m'a dit oui tulle aime beaucoup
et tu te cache pas donc est ce que tu
comptes faire revenir à l'idrac comme
chroniqueur mais nous continuerons à
l'anniversaire demain et on sera bien
sûr les missions normales bercy jean
michel lambert carl lourdeur mercier
d'abord être avec nous remercier pour
tous vos messages
vous me dire merci je voudrais dire
merci aussi à mon lolo qui est avec moi
tous les soirs 1re là qui travaillent
qui font un travail formidable et c'est
avec lui que j'ai signé mon premier
contrat
je vous le dis or au short de tennis
donc c'est lui aussi qui était avec moi
des depuis les dix ans et fabrice konkaï
corée avec moi tous les soirs là les
deux et lionel voilà voilà tout le monde
voilà tout ce que paris et ceux des pnp
aouicha tout ça je remercierai to work
as khroub et bien sûr mon frérot et on
les a tous eu sinon voilà par srx isère
aussi mon chéri à la merci à tous et je
vous êtes port et surtout merci à vous